we we're going to pull this up we're
going to do this segment on this one
we're going to do it norm mcdonald's
this is the best oh vince foster deputy
white house counsel have you ever seen
the norm mcdonald on the view bill
clinton murdered a guy oh boy let's uh
barbara walter says look at her
you're supposed to see him uh yeah
that's a little desperate in it
let's jump into
a lie or crook murder or anything like i
love george bush man he's a good man
decent you know none of this
false
yeah he's uh you know he's not a
a lie or a crook murderer or anything
like that so it'd be good to get the see
i i don't i think we should get the
homicide out of the white house and get
like a a a fresh start because we don't
want any more murderers i think we
should just go on to the next question
oh my god well clinton murdered a guy
wow
that's a little too that's the way it
does let's just let's just go on to the
next move
all
oh it's not mine either i'm being very
nice okay
be a good boy
now norm do you never hear that no
listen we don't need no one get
accusations and you're supposed to be
funny
this is a live show
but you have been properly chastised by
i'm not going to ask the next question i
thought it was a matter of record
okay let me do this okay
i'll tell you what's a matter of record
you will not be invited back if you
don't shut up
[Laughter]
i certainly hope that somebody calling
to tell you to go home oh no dude you
got a phone ringing this is the producer
he gives it out
um
hello
oh yeah oh no uh the thing is this
there uh you know matt strauss yeah the
producer the producer he told me it
would be funny he said like why don't
you carry a cell phone on and then let
it ring and then have pretend like
there's a guy on it
no it's a
a really good point in there though she
says let's talk about football because
listen i used to love professional
sports but that is what distracts us tim
from really what's going on they give us
bread and circuses oh my gosh i'm going
to drink my beer on sunday and what's
the dallas cowboys lose for the you know
100th straight yeah you know when i was
younger i was very much like i wish
people stopped focusing on the on the
sports and paid attention to politics
but now that really really dumb people
are treating politics like sports i'm
like maybe that was a bad idea yeah but
sports listen lebron james he's never
read past the first page of a book no he
votes and he gets political and he comes
out and he campaigns and it's like stop
please please stop you don't read you
know what you're talking about but who
does he defend the most china so
my point being is sports are great
that's part of american culture baseball
yeah we gotta hit jane i don't do good
impressions but what i'm saying is
sports are important i think for the
youth it gives them some sort of
structure i think you know skateboarding
anything i'm saying any athletic prowess
is good for young people instead of
sitting and just playing a game um
speaking of i want to actually make this
point this is what i envision the future
is i actually believe believe that we're
going to have some sort of vanilla sky
matrix future where people
are going to be so
their lives are going to be so you know
tumultuous outside of it that they're
going to actually convince people to
plug into what is called the metaverse
very similar to the matrices and they're
going to say listen we're going to
intubate you and in the metaverse ian
you're going to have you know a 10 inch
you know what you're going to you know
you're going to have you're going to be
dating a supermodel all the people so so
it would be smaller
okay but what i'm saying is uh
my point being is that you're going to
have a beautiful supermodel life and
instead of living your 72 years on
average here on earth you're gonna live
for a thousand years and you can look
this up they're actually talking about
prison census for people where you can
make somebody think that they had a ten
thousand year sentence
in a week you could be in it right now
you could you know you're like wondering
why your life sucks why you're poor and
it's like you're in jail yeah you know
but what my point being is
is the you know the technology that
they're gonna have and there's a thing
called the uncanny valley and actually
uh i forget the exact term for it but
like a t verizon what they do is they
try to actually get like when you call a
um a robot basically to try to get
customer service they're trying to
create technology where you can't tell
that you're talking to a robot and they
can't do it if they're ever tested they
can't do it because there's a thing
called uncanny valley where they can't
make it exactly like a human it's not
going to have the same
speech pattern it's you're always
someday they will though maybe well you
say that you say that and that's why i
don't necessarily think they will
because i think it's almost impossible
and the reason why is you say oh
artificial intelligence we'll be able to
create that really artificial
intelligence just takes basically it can
make future decisions for you based on
past decisions but the idea that it can
be you and me there's some sort of
uniqueness about us that i do believe is
impossible to recreate i think that
could be our soul personally but i just
think it's almost impossible there's
artificial emotion there's a there's a
movie where they invent there's like eye
drops was it a movie or a show i don't
know and then it simulates an experience
and so like this woman like puts the eye
drops in and then in the span of like 10
minutes she spends a weekend in aspen
and then her business partner's like
i've got a better use for this prison
sentences that's nice and then she's
like you can't do this and then they
fight and then she like pins him down
and she like you know he like puts the
drop in her eye and forces her into like
a thousand-year prison chamber it's like
all psychological so there's literally
no way to escape you could also make it
where it it it happened like you
experienced 10 seconds in the metaverse
but when you come out it's 70 years
later and real you'd be dead though yeah
that's a way to like comatose people so
here's a thought here's a thought
what if
your life your mundane life where you're
trying to live right you're trying to be
a good person you're resisting all this
woke communism garbage in reality you
are a woke communist
who was involved in some anti-violence
and so you were sentenced to re
rehabilitation where they make you live
a life on the other side to experience
violence from them so that when you
finally come out you're like i can't
stand those people and then you're like
whoa i was those people
now i get it and you've been
reprogrammed well it's like inception
but i'll be honest you know we talk
about the prison industry and you know a
lot of people on the conservative side
will say systemic racism doesn't exist
but for me i do believe it exists
because you look at a lot of the
non-violent drug offenders in jail are
african-american or black so i do think
we have a prison system a private prison
industry in america that's a huge
business it goes along with a lot of the
military-industrial complex the
pharmaceutical industrial complex once
again it's the american people being
sold out to corporations to make money
this guy's a liberal a kind of and i i
wouldn't be against universal health
care in some form not necessarily the
way they want it but i'm saying at least
less taxes there should be a way where
people are so afraid tim i know a lot of
people i'm in the bail bond business we
actually get people out of jail so
that's why prison reform's a big deal to
me but i know people that are afraid to
call an ambulance and will take an uber
to
the hospital because they can't afford
an ambulance so i'm not saying canada's
system's good i don't know what system
i'm not that smart right dude i took i
took a taxi to the hospital once exact
see yeah right there i called a cab i i
had a uh i had a kidney stone and it hit
me like elves and out of nowhere
crippling pain and i was like quick call
green cab uber think about that tim you
should have been able to call an
ambulance i agree completely and uh i'm
like dude 50 bucks in an uber or 500 an
ambulance
it's more than 500 right yeah i don't
like um chronic
uh healthcare universal healthcare for
chronic stuff like someone eats too much
you know universal health powers
you know it's going to suck but i just
feel like it's a better alternative a
kid breaks his arm instead of some mom
being like yeah how am i going to pay
for emergency health care emergency
universities that's chronic where it's
like they don't stop eating poison and
then they get sick it's like dude you
did that to yourself i'm not here but i
gotta say this point why is why is
diabetes medicine you know 170 in
america but in mexico it's five dollars
why is dental care the same thing why is
it that all of my ancap friends are like
oh i got to get my teeth fixed i'll be
flying uh you know uh to mexico city or
costa rica costa rica especially they
argue that it's cosmetic
not medical right that's it's nonsense
and here's the crazy thing too in mexico
and in costa rica they do this thing
where after they do the work on your
teeth they take your own blood and and
put it over the the damaged part of your
mouth from the surgery and it heals way
faster yeah your own blood because it it
heals you right they don't do that here
as far as i know i was talking to
somebody and i looked it up and i was
like if you go to costa rica it's like a
tenth of the price with better treatment
i'm like that doesn't make sense tim
what doesn't make sense is that we
prescribe antidepressants to people that
are suicidal that makes you more
the
suicidal
freaking side effect in the commercial
you'll see somebody dancing in a field
oh may cause suicidal idolization or
idealization it's like what you're
giving that to people that are suicidal
i mean isn't that counterintuitive yeah
the sooner you get on the
anti-depressants the better it'll heal
you but as soon as they came out mental
health issues skyrocketed what are the
chances i can accept that we have that
there's a war machine that the united
states is in in control of but what
happens when corporations try to take
control of it and and poison and subdue
the population through other kinds of
means non-violent means like like
psychedelic psychoactives that's not
cool i don't want to lose control of the
war machine by point by going after our
own people false flags
pharmaceutical induction like that i'm
not comfortable with i'm i'm down to
hold on to the military and make sure
that we have a stable planet where the
hungry people aren't rioting and
destroying everyone else to steal their
food
but man the pharmaceutical industry
pisses me off of course but but i do
want to say my favorite thing mcdonald's
french fries so i do i'm thankful for
the genetically modified uh
mcdonald's i don't understand how people
eat mcdonald's i don't grow
no no no i get burger king burger king i
like b.k
sausage mcgriddle yes i just think it's
terrible good there's not a single item
at mcdonald's i think tastes good tim
they interject the pancake with syrup
right which i love that method listen
burger but it gets like burger king
burger king i find delicious but
disgusting wendy's i find delicious and
not that bad pretty good chick-fil-a as
lady point out the other day actually
probably the best
is good it's like premiums yeah but it's
not gay enough so you can't go there
yeah well now it is now they've like
they're gay the chickens are getting
postcards
they started supporting all these
organizations yeah i'm pretty sure what
you're talking about postmates and i
want to thank postmates because they
have a bottom friendly menu and that's
so good yeah we love the bottom friendly
menu that's that well you don't want
that you don't want to poop all over the
place no no no but mcdonald's
to me it is it's all tastes like plastic
and chemicals i just i just i don't know
exactly and you know it's created in a
lab to do that that's why it had a
mechanism in your taste buds you're like
oh this is addicting and the more you
eat mcdonald's the more you crave
mcdonald's you know the worst thing is
the mayonnaise at mcdonald's is like
flavorless slime
flavorless burger king that's good well
you see those chicken nuggets that pink
slime ooh it's delicious when it hits
your lips because the chemical reaction
in your brain it is like you know almost
like crack cocaine it causes you know
euphoric sensation to some people you
know what i had today i had tuna
it's funny so you're very the trim
though tim i didn't realize you're in
good shape wow i lost a lot of weight
since since uh november of last year i
stopped eating sugar grains cut out the
wheat the wheat apparently is like the
worst part it's inflammatory i guess i'm
not a nutritionist i don't know a lot
but you look good all i know is i was
like i don't want to eat the bread or
the rice or the fried anymore so i
started eating a lot of chicken wings
that's like
70 of my diet right in an air fryer or
what no just regular chicken wings like
do you bake them because you said no
fried i just go to the restaurant say
give me chicken wings i love it i like
old bay wings like so there's no extra
sauce or anything on them oh bait rocks
yeah
that's delicious
of course and then uh uh for breakfast
i've been doing like we have our farm
fresh eggs like the chickens poop amount
i just eat that with like some uh some
like local cheese or something people
have been talking about how uh
in particular has
a very
deep like food quality problem compared
to the eu
because we don't have strict enough
regulations
from the fda and our our regulatory
agencies think it's the way around
yeah do you think the eu is too strict
no we are too strict yeah we are yeah so
uh
so like our eggs are like what are they
like stripped bleached and like
our milk is so processed yeah yeah yeah
yeah raw milk is illegal in some cases
come on raw milk is illegal you know
what else is
no they're illegal in new york and
connecticut what if you ate one here and
went back to new york and they're like
it's in your system isn't it
testing you for wine get down
so uh uh yeah wine raspberries are
everywhere they're invasive they're
thick brambles and they grow like crazy
and they're delicious by the way people
love it but in new york and connecticut
they're illegal to possess
or sell or trade but fentanyl's not
that's decriminalized so yeah well
that's the funny thing i'd be willing to
bet if you were in new york and you like
brutally beat someone they'd let you out
of jail but if you're caught with wine
berries it'll be like serious violation
yeah i mean that just shows you the
hypocrisy of the rules in new york in
you know a big district like we said aoc
who's the queen of new york you know
people are literally defending their
bodegas and going to jail there's a
point that i made the other day uh so we
ordered this uh like you can order these
like food things
um one of the things that we promote on
the podcast version of the show is the
moink box and it's like farm fresh meats
delivered right to your door and so we
got one of those but with seafoods like
scallops prawns fish and i'm eating this
wild white alaskan salmon that is so
delicious and that's all it is you know
it's like lemon pepper on it with some
like avocado tim do you use an air fryer
i hope you're using an airfryer do you
have an airfryer in this house yeah it's
the best kitchen airfry salmon actually
they say it's good in there i don't eat
salmon no i swear they say you can air
fry it's delicious what i said was
this is an expensive thing to order like
to order this wild caught salmon to like
to your door and then i'm like it's
funny if you're like well off in america
you're eating food quality up here if
you're middle to lower class you're
eating food quality way down here if you
live in south america and africa you're
eating food quality way up here it's
crazy that the poorest people in the
world not everywhere not not some of
them are eating mud but there are areas
where people have like mud huts but they
walk out catch a fish and are eating
fresh caught salmon and that is better
quality food than the mac and cheese
mcdonald's stuff that people are eating
in this country and americans get sick
when they go to countries like that
because they're not used to eating real
food thanks for checking out this clip
from timcast irl come hang out live
monday through friday at 8 pm eastern
time super chat will even answer some of
your questions if you want to check out
the after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time